it appears now according to the
Ukrainian Air Force 81 missiles at least
were fired on Ukraine they say they
brought down 34 cruise missiles I mean
this is only what we've had from them at
least six people have been killed
they're basically going after a power
infrastructure of course we haven't seen
this for about the last three weeks or
so but it has been going on for a very
long time the idea is to disrupt an
ordinary functioning of the state to
demoralize the people here they're out
back trying to get that energy supplies
back but obviously obviously they're
they're mopping up where where some of
the missiles struck because we know that
there are the air defense systems can
actually also strike the ground and and
hit houses we've seen that over the over
the last year or so so there'll be sort
of an analysis of what happened here but
it is a pretty significant development
that's an awful lot of uh missiles being
fired into the country once again and of
course the fighting goes on particularly
in back mood as well and then I think
there is going to obviously be a lot of
concern about the nuclear power station
it's not been hit per se it's off the
power grid it has generators that can
last for 10 days or so but they will be
trying to get power back to that but it
is you know very very dangerous uh power
plants nuclear power plants have to have
power all the time to keep the reactors
cool so that will be a major concern of
course Russia has been condemned by
politicians here for attacking a
civilian infrastructure once again but
there's nothing to indicate that that's
going to stop it's just there's been a
lull rather than a stop in that policy